hey everybody it's Mike from motor flows
and in today's video you know I'm going
to reply to a question I actually
applied to reply to it in the comments
uh the other day but you know this is a
question I've gotten many many times
over the years and I thought I'd just
shoot a quick video uh explaining it
because this is a question that you know
a lot of Traders you know have is you
know what type of chart should I be
using
um you know sometimes I I talk mostly
about a time-based chart like a one
minute chart or sometimes even a five
minute chart but I also look at range
based charts and you know the way
they're constructed obviously is going
to be different so you know in the video
the other day I was talking about Bonds
on a five minute chart and
if you've been around long enough you
know if I mean if you traded for at
least 10 years you'll know that you know
markets evolve and now we're sort of in
this time where you know things are a
lot more volatile you know in the past
you know going back to this is an old
footprint chart from 20 what is this
2015 this is
um the March Bonds in 2015. and you can
see you know you're looking at a range
this is pretty much the day's range this
is when I was still
um back in Asia so it looks like you
know midnight but this is actually
during the US day session you know 141
even up to about uh you know 140 116 for
pretty much the whole entire session
whereas now in the US you know just
going back to Friday you know from you
know we'll take it from eight in the
morning where it's eight in the morning
here more or less coming in at 131 even
um down to you know 1 30 even so with
and that's just within two hours so you
know you're getting a full point move in
two hours whereas you know years ago you
would get a much smaller move and
you know in the past I
focused a lot of my attention on
range-based charts and
you know the reason being you know when
markets are slower they range-based
charts in my opinion will pick up
um momentum a little bit quicker right
because you know the difference between
a time-based chart and a range based
chart is how they're formed a time-based
chart it doesn't it just you know if
you're using a one minute chart after 60
seconds boom a new bar is going to be
formed right if you're using a five
minute chart 457 458 459 5 minutes boom
a new bar is going to be formed whereas
a range based chart
is formed you know how price moves in
comparison to its highs and lows right
if it's going to start moving
um
you know outside of its range right
because it's a range based chart and you
know there are pluses and negatives on
both type of charts you know I just
explained one of the negatives with the
time based chart in that it's you know
it's literally
starts and ends at a predetermined time
that's it whereas you know if you're
looking at a range based chart
you know when a number comes out so for
example on Friday you know 7 30 or 1 7
30 01 730 01 730.02 you know we formed
was it four bars within two seconds
whereas you know even up to here 7 30 55
on a one minute chart you know if this
move from 131.09 down to you know 130 12
is just one bar but there's on a
range-based chart it's one two three
four five six seven eight you know nine
bars you know but that being said you
know I do look at both charts because
you know sometimes you want to get
insight into Market activity
on a range based chart that I'm not
going to see on a time-based chart and
you know and again vice versa which one
is better well it all comes down to you
know what you want to see in the on the
chart you know and you know what's
important to you in the order flow right
order flow is just not looking at the
bid ask or looking where wrestling
liquidity is you know there's there's
order flow is so robust you know you
could take into account you know point
of control imbalances
um Delta and you know that there's just
so many different ways that you can be
using this this information and
sometimes you're going to see things
um on the Range based chart that you
might not pick up on a Time based chart
okay especially if a market is dead in
the water I mean unfortunately now we
don't really get those quiet periods in
these markets you know markets tend to
move uh pretty quickly and you know that
being said
especially in volatile markets with
rapid price movements you know
range-based charts may be more
responsive as they adjust faster to you
know prices going up or prices going
down whereas you know on a time-based
chart it's just going to stay in the
same bar whereas on a range based chart
you're going to get a lot of bars
starting to print
okay so you know that's how you know
when I say it's a little bit more
responsive
um that's what I mean but you're going
to be looking at the same things whether
you're looking at a one minute chart
five minute chart five range chart so
let me just duplicate this chart and you
know we'll take a look you know sort of
at them side by side
um actually I should have opened this in
a uh
new window let me just do that real
quick I'll change this to a five range
five minute chart so I got the five
range chart here
and let's put them a little side by side
so you could get a better
you know sort of a better Glimpse here
come on get up there
expand this down expand this down whoops
that's the whole chart from 2015.
seven years ago
um you see how
how different the your voice Trader
software looks now you know it's just
the basic plain footprint back then now
we've got a lot more information right
now but what I've got is just the normal
footprint
um so let's just go back here to
you know this time here at eight o'clock
okay go back here to
eight o'clock so this is a five minute
chart here
this is a five range chart
and again you know
you're seeing on the
five minute chart right you can see
obviously the longer bars the shorter
bars whereas on the five range chart
everything is you know pretty it's
pretty set right honestly
um on this
well here let me turn on some things
here so
we get a better clue as to how this
Market is moving now we turn on stack
the simple things stacked imbalances
um
volume imbalance where are you here
just so you can see here that's multiple
imbalances
so many things in here
we are stacked in balance okay
then I'll open it up here
just so you can see what I'm talking
about a little bit better
and we'll just sort of compare some of
these things
sort of what we're seeing here in the
markets
okay stacked in Balance here so
obviously you know the bars are formed
differently volumes in the bars are
going to be different you can see here
this is at eight o'clock the high 64.91
you know this is a green bar you get
that high up there on the green candle
the market starts coming off here it's
actually on a red candle right and then
the market starts coming off what you
see right after we put in this High here
on the five range is a stack selling
imbalance you don't see that coming in
here on the five minute chart a little
bit later
um you know a few ticks lower coming in
at 22 to 20 you've got a stack selling a
balance but you don't have that coming
in here at uh you know between 22 and
20. you still have that selling and
balance coming in here the 226 but you
don't have those other imbalances
because within that range you know there
was
it was trading back and forth It's
almost like the top of this
bar here these two bars is combined is
kind of what you're seeing
but again if you're just looking at
stacked imbalances well on the Range
base chart it's going to come in it's
coming in a little bit quicker you're
not seeing it in here on the time base
chart
okay
um you know just sort of scroll over
here now
this is coming in at
nine o'clock okay
what we have here let me just turn this
on
is what we call a Prominent Point of
control all right Prominent Point of
control is a point of control that's
acting as support or resistance let me
just turn that enable that one on
and
you know
I'll just make it until tested
so it stands out a little bit more
okay
right there
I'll turn it on here on the five minute
chart
Prime opponent control
there we go until tested
and this is a primary point of control
it's indicating that there's resistance
here right you don't see it coming in
even though it's the same volume in here
13 and 171 why because in this bar this
is a five range chart so you know the
bars are going to be a little bit
smaller
um Market starts selling off here it's
just mixed in with this bar right here
I've got a bullish Prominent Point to
control this magenta
Prominent Point of control coming in at
that's at 8 40.
but in the range based chart it's just
sort of combined in this one bar right
what you're seeing with this one two
three price levels here at 08 right
right here at 08 on the Range base chart
right since we're sort of going sideways
in here
um you know this area between you know
130 uh 11 and you know 130.07 you know
right in here it's formed in one bar but
on the five minute you know
five minute ends gotta start a new bar
five minute ends got to start a new bar
five minute ends it starts a new bar
whereas here on the Range base chart
it's just all combined in there
okay so here you do have a bullish
primary point of control
but you don't have the bearish Prominent
Point of control so you know there's
like I said there's
advantages and disadvantages sometimes
you're going to see things on the
um
chart
you know the time-based chart that
you're not going to see on the
range base chart so for example here's a
bullish polymer point of control coming
in at 10 30 right and you get this
little bit of a move up from you know
basically 04 up to O8 whereas on this
chart right you can see this Market is
very quiet now right it's quieted down
most of these bars are just trading you
know the bid offer plus one tick above
or one tick below right it's three ticks
whereas here so this is 10 30 to you
know 10 55 okay 10 30 10 55 on the five
minute chart well
here on the five range chart
basically 10 30 this is two contracts up
here that's the two contracts up there
is
you know basically it's just one bar
right here it takes about 15 minutes to
form
okay whereas so you're not going to see
this trade here that you're seeing on
here and you're seeing buying a balance
buying a balance buying a balance behind
them but you're seeing it from down here
buying and balance buying and balance
buying a balance so you know there's
some aggressive buying going on whereas
on the
range based chart you know from 10 20
right in here you're not seeing those
bind imbalances
okay then you start seeing the selling
balances come in here
and the market sort of goes sideways
whereas here you know this is you don't
see the sign of balances come in it's
not until 11 43 that you see some strong
selling coming in
um you know on this
um
11 43 here you've got this stack selling
a balance so you're not picking up
necessarily all right if you if you
watch the point of controls where volume
or balance is taking place in the market
right in here I mean this is obvious if
you're watching
um if you're watching the the point of
controls in the order flow on a
time-based chart you see two get aligned
up here then you got one two three four
five at O3 basically we're trading O3
for 30 minutes then we start to break
down below it and you got a stack
selling the balance which is a strong
signal that hey you know what we could
probably punch a little bit lower
okay but it just you get the stacks on
the bounce goes sideways before it sort
of drops another five ticks but on here
you just see it as as one bar right
you're seeing all these bars
one two three four five six bars
basically coming in in this one bar so
here you're seeing that stacks on a
balance but you're not necessarily
seeing it
um
here on the Range base chart
okay so again you know there there are
certain things that are unique to
different types of charts right
time-based chart obviously it's going to
be based on time and as soon as that
time is over it's going to form a new
bar period okay but it leaves Footprints
like this so to speak because this is a
footprint chart
um you know what you're seeing over time
the market balanced but on the Range
based chart you might not pick it up I
mean you know unless you're really
paying attention you know you think is a
slow period obviously it is but this one
bar you know opened up basically 11 16
and it ended up at 11 40. three so you
know you're talking you know close to 30
minutes right right in here but if
you're looking at this time-based chart
you're saying oh you know what we're
just going sideways in here we're
putting a balance area maybe I could
watch it when it breaks out whereas here
you know maybe you're not paying as much
attention to it
okay but once the market starts moving
you know on a Time based on sorry on a
range-based chart sometimes it's a
little bit more obvious because you're
going to start to see more bars forming
you know here right go back to this nine
o'clock
right nine o'clock when it's got this
one bar here
you just say well it's a big bar down
but if you're watching it here at nine
o'clock you've seen one bar form two
bars form three bars form within the
five minute period whereas here it's
just you know one longer bar so
um
I look at both of them you know honestly
I don't want to say that I don't look at
a range based chart or I only look at a
time-based chart you know there's
information there's tradable things in
both of them
um you know whether I'm looking at
prominent important controls or you know
another thing I like to look at is the
value areas okay so let's throw those
value areas up on here
um
okay I'll just throw up the plane value
area
so that's on the Range based chart
now the value area is this is something
that's on the order flows Trader six and
again it's very useful for helping
identify when a market is
you know moving away from
balance or from value however you want
to describe it I use the term balance
and value pretty uh interchangeably
okay
okay so let's just go back to this nine
o'clock time okay so this is the bar
here on the five range this is that same
bar at nine o'clock on the uh five
minute chart
now
what I see here right this is the value
area this red area of the bar the
because it's a red bar so it's printing
it uh red the green bars it prints it
green and what I'm seeing you know while
this is a bearish
value area
it's taking place in that one bar okay
here I can see it's bearish is bearish
is bearish in the sense that I have a
gap between this value and this value
this value and this value here I just
have it in that one bar then it just
sort of starts to overlap
um let's go back to
um you know some of these higher areas
the time is the 757 let me just go back
to around this just before eight o'clock
in here okay
this is that stacked selling and balance
coming in at 22 so that's right over
this is 21 this is 22.
while this
is kind of a bearish looking value area
it's not as clear as what I'm seeing
taking place on the Range base chart
right because I'm seeing a gap between
this value area and this value area
right then obviously another gap down
here anytime I have a gap in value areas
it's telling me the market is you know
potentially getting ready to make a move
um
let's just expand on the value areas a
little bit further
again I'm just comparing the five range
to the five minute chart I'm not really
uh getting into much deep analysis
because
um you know looking at the type of chart
you know deciding on the type of chart
that you want to use or you know what
you want to look at for things
you know it's a personal decision right
it's not like oh well Mike says I got to
use a a five minute chart or a five
range chart no you know look at the
charts if it's easier for you to see
things on on a five minute chart then
use the five minute chart if it's easier
for you to see things on a five range
chart then use the five range chart
right trading is kind of a personal
Endeavor right you got to find what
makes sense to you you know look at the
market
in ways that it makes sense to you okay
so
here right this is nine this is what we
call the Eva right the um expanding
value area it's a bullish sign on the
five minute chart I've got a bearish one
here a bearish one here then a bullish
one here on the five range chart I don't
have it here this is at nine o'clock
that's at nine o'clock
um this one came in at 9 20. I don't
have it at 9 20.
um you know there's the bullish one here
it just sort of went sideways afterwards
at 9 40. but I don't have any on the
five
um
on the five range chart here but on the
Range on the five minute chart you know
I've got this one this one
and this one that just went sideways so
again you know you're seeing things
on different types of charts but you'd
still look for the same things right
just because you're looking at a five
minute chart doesn't mean
you're not still paying attention to
that same thing on the five range chart
it's just some for some people it's a
little bit easier to pick things up on a
um
time-based chart
and for others it's a little bit easier
on a range based chart
again you know this is the the
five minute chart you know this is the
day before the Thursday right the
bearish value area right you can see
it's just sort of just you know a little
bit lower I'm not saying yeah oh yeah
big sell-off and now it just sort of
hung around there
um you know and move down whereas on the
let me close this one down go back here
um just go back the previous day this is
the five range chart
on the eighth
yeah I mean you don't have it there
right you still you got some imbalances
but on the Range based chart you don't
have those
um bearish value areas
right these are just stack selling and
balances coming in
um right when the number
came out on Friday so again you know is
there one right or wrong chart to look
at no right you find the chart that
makes reading the market easiest for you
that's what it comes down to so
you know I hope this answers that
original question you know it's kind of
a
that's a hard question to answer
specifically to a specific Trader you
know it takes time to to pick up you
know things in the market what you're
going to focus on and again you know
sometimes it's easier on a range based
chart you're going to see things that
you might not see on a Time based chart
and vice versa
all right so
again you know guys
if you've got any questions you know be
sure to put them in the comments section
and you know I'll I'll get to them in
time sometimes you know now I I'm gonna
try and make videos on them it's a
little bit easier than typing it out
um you know I've got a few other
questions I want to get to in some later
videos you know about settings you know
what what should you know what's a good
setting for 10 years or mini Dao or gold
um but again you know it really depends
on the type of Trader you are right not
everybody trades the same not everybody
has the same
um
what is that same risk risk tolerance
you know some people take a drawdown of
500 or some Traders draw down of 200
they're already Sweating Bullets
um you know so it really depends on on
yourself as a Trader
what your risk tolerance is in a certain
market and that that's going to help you
determine what type of chart you're
going to look at okay because there's no
right or wrong answer that's what kills
me the most if you read Market Wizards
right all those guys they got different
ways of trading they're all brilliant
Traders but they look at the market
through different lenses
all right some people you know some guys
were on the floor in that book so they
got a very short-term view other guys
were macro guys they have very long-term
view is one way better than the other no
it's it's one way is
what's best for you you individually
right and that that's the thing is you
know sometimes people like to try and
force themselves into you know think of
it like the those kids toys right the
the box with the square the triangle and
and the circle right sometimes it's like
trying to fit a square peg
into the circle hole it's just not going
to fit and you know it's trying to force
yourself into
being a certain type of Trader in a way
that that's not natural to you
is you know a recipe for a disaster so I
hope you guys like this video you know
be sure to like And subscribe and and
keep those comments uh positive and and
comments you know in the videos if you
got questions and hopefully um I can get
to them
so hope you enjoyed this video guys I'll
see you guys on the next video bye-bye